we're on the road we're driving our 67
Impala with the weapons loaded in the
trunk and we're we're hunting
as young boys we lost our our mother to
something unexplainable something
paranormal and our father and sit well
it didn't sit real well with him so he
made it kind of his life mission to
track down this evil force or this
unexplicable thing and and deal with it
and in doing so in making it his life
mission he trained his two boys to be
equally as skilled a little and skilled
in that craft demon hunting ghost
hunting these two boys grew up weapons
training fighting and you know learning
about folklore and mythology and urban
legends and everything that goes bump in
the night and dad set out and Dean my
character followed in his footsteps and
and made it his his quest as well and
Sam decided to stray from the from the
family biz so to speak and by the end of
the first episode gets yanked back into
it and the two brothers hit the road and
some would have a search for their
father and along the way they they run
into the legends and folklore and they
deal with them the way they know how we
go where to do that kind of worried me
at first
not that you know charmed and Roswell
and Buffy and Angel weren't all great
shows in their own right but I wasn't
interested in doing a show of that genre
and though this is also technically a
supernatural show it's nothing like
those there's nothing like those four
and it's it's just something that's
super special and super unique to the
network and to to both of us and I was
really excited once I read the script
and once I I'm at the the writer Kripke
and some of the producers in the
director and heard their vision and I
was like wow like this is gonna be
insane
we've got the car on set we're cruising
down that dusty highway for sure both of
us both of us it's his car but but I
think that I inherited the car from dad
right but it's it's very much a
partnership between the two roads so are
the car stuff
I sure hope so not quite yet but we're
only the first episode in so I would
assume that that's going to be a large
portion of the show for sure
bringing boxing and weightlifting and
running and you know doing
cardiovascular training you know circuit
training and stuff and getting our our
bodies into shape so that we can both
deal with the days and and and look at
look like people who actually know what
we're doing and weapons training comes
it it comes also with that and we kind
of do episode episode say you know we're
using a double-barrel shotgun sawed off
or episode three you know we'll go to
the prop masters and we'll explore that
and we'll go find a day to go to the
range and you know kind of tinker around
with get familiar with all the things
that we'll be dealing most of the demons
or creatures or spirits are gonna be
tangible and so a lot of it can be done
just with an actual camera but they're
gonna be visual effects definitely in
special effects every episode it just
depends yeah this isn't made up this is
I mean this is Eric Kripke you know
genius he is he's been thinking about
this for you know nearly a decade
researching and knows it like the back
of his hand there's a whole subculture
about this folklore stuff I mean in
everything that we do you know laying
assault or rent in a circle and putting
cat's eye shells down and stuff this is
all very you know relevant stuff to to
this kind of folklore so it's it's kind
of neat to be particles in a sense we're
also learning about the stuff as well
exactly what's your arm look at x-files
yeah yeah yeah I think it does
especially their cookie and sort of his
vast array of knowledge of a folklore
and mythology and everything there's
really good to see you again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]